Craigslist is so sketchy though yeah
Craigslist feels like every time I'm on
it like I feel like I'm getting an STD
from that website
[Music]
all right we got a warning an official
Nationwide warning from the FBI right
now for B yeah they're warning us
they're warning all of us all the female
body inspectors oh yeah they got a they
got a big warning big big warning I
there's a huge influx of property rental
scams
this year it's up 64 64
.
yep it's super up and like listen to
this uh this isn't this is last year 11
000 about 11.5 people they reported
losing uh 350 million dollars just to
scams alone oh that's a lot how how does
the scam go well they can range from
stuff that's super simple to like crazy
stuff but one really really popular
example is the the [ __ ] classic
Craigslist one where someone says hey
I'm renting this property and they they
place it way below market so it's super
attractive and then you tell them you're
interested and they say okay well then
uh I need 150 for the credit check and
then they send that in and then they go
okay 500 bucks deposit I'll take the
listing off and then you can come see it
once the current tenants are out so then
they send the money to take the listing
off and then just never hear from them
again and then they go to that address
and they find that people live there and
it's not even up for it's probably
easier because during covet everything
was remote so then they had to send the
deposit and things online anyway so yeah
yeah so and people were just used to
doing online transactions and especially
if someone was still living there you
would they wouldn't want you walking
through to like look at their place like
during covert yeah Craigslist is so
sketchy though yeah Craigslist feels
like every time I'm on it like I feel
like I get an STD from that website
which is which is why you gotta put like
gloves on before you use a computer the
Craigslist itch yeah but you only go
there for a certain type of like thing
you know what I mean you don't go there
to buy your house the only thing they
did change was the adult section that
took out all because they used to have
escorts yeah other than that it's been
the same right and it just feels like
it's a scammer's [ __ ] like Gateway
yeah honestly it seems like the escort
section was probably the most legit part
like trust me I am who I say I am yeah
this is the one that's it's trustworthy
you're actually paying for a service you
want you know I will literally [ __ ] your
brains out I promise dude do you know of
any like real estate scams that you you
tell like your clients to watch out for
or anything like mortgage I think after
2000 and I think after 2008 all the
scale kind of like died out but the
biggest scam I think is rent to own so
they create this hope and this dream
that if you pay rent here whatever you
pay above fair market rate goes towards
a down payment like is that like at
least to own police
are like
um the chances that someone's actually
going to be able to afford to qualify to
buy it's really Slim enough so they got
you to uh to live there you're paying
this rent and you're paying above that
amount and you're treated like a
homeowner so something goes wrong with
the property you you're gonna own it oh
wow that sucks and so you're like
climbing up this ladder oh there's
another bill crap there's another
building homeowner so it's like to get
to that point where you actually have
the full down payment and still
qualifying it's very slim to none and
then next but why are you overpaying
because that difference you pay goes
towards the down payment so let's say
fair market are they saving it yes so to
qualify it so it's a mortgage guideline
that it's like I knew the guideline the
loophole I'm gonna take it to the next
level so whatever you pay above fair
market rent can go towards the down
payment and of course as the person's
renting there they get all the
responsibilities as a homeowner but they
don't own the property so how do you
keep saving towards that down payment if
something keeps going wrong with the
house yeah and then eventually they got
you they got all that money and then
you're out and then they have a better
and someone else someone else just fixed
the washer and dryer and they fixed it
all that and then they got to get leave
so I think that's the biggest scam there
are legit ones but not as many as people
think have you heard a leasehold
please hold so they have this term in um
Hawaii called fee simple or leasehold
right so fee simple you actually it's
like a traditional ownership you own the
land you do whatever for a leasehold you
actually lease the land but it's your
property
so it's not quite yours huh yeah and
then the contract is for whatever
duration oh okay like 30 years or 100
years or whatever right so technically
you you temporarily own it but it's not
yours so like Hong Kong was maybe but
but it's a weird situation because it's
like so like let's say you can at least
hold a unit in a a condo unit right yeah
and so it'll be dramatically cheaper but
it's not your land you can't you know it
you don't you can't use it for
collateral you can't do anything that is
the most yours that I've ever heard
that's crazy yeah so you you're you're
in charge of the whole property
but it's not yours let's say you're in
you're in conflict with the actual owner
and you need to part ways
do you gotta hire a helicopter to like
peel your building a building away from
the land and then drop it off somewhere
there's probably some because your
property is like yours but the land's
not right yeah the building is yours but
the land is not I'm gonna move it that's
the biggest problem yeah that's gonna be
loud I think the biggest well I think
people how are you gonna pull your unit
outside of the building if it's one of
those two yeah do you [ __ ] cut off
some people think this is a scam some
people don't think it's a scam you know
I think everyone has their own opinion
uh wholesaling so when you find a
property that you can convince someone
to sell to you at a discount and then
you reassign the sell to someone else
yeah some people think it's a scam
because you're prey on people who don't
know better they don't you know you
scare them so much where they don't want
to list the property on the open market
and then some people think hey they're
the ones who will need to sell it to me
why is it a scam so a lot of um
wholesalers become more popular they'll
look for properties that are jacked up
or for older people hey this is how much
you can get for the property I was able
to get you more but they've already they
already have an investor they already
reassigned it to some people think
that's fair because you know you're
willing to you know they were willing to
sell it to me you know most these
wholesalers are licensed but then some
people think it's completely wrong to do
that yeah I mean they do that in all
kinds of markets don't they like they
did it with cars in a way I think it
might be considered predatory but I
don't know if it's illegal because
you're just basically
basically to me it's [ __ ] up because
you're dealing with people who don't
know so you're taking advantage of their
ignorance what if they don't want to
know they're just like hey I don't want
to deal with this then that's that's
different that's what garyvee does he's
like oh buy this [ __ ] Beanie Baby for
seven bucks okay
two hundred thousand dollars
exactly it is yeah with everything so
whose fault is it is it because the
people were ignorant or is it because
you came in and you gave them
misinformation I think it depends on how
you how you bought it yeah so like if
you bought it just saying hey I'm
offering you seven bucks for this Beanie
Baby they take it cool but if you go you
know what you're probably not gonna get
anything for this but I'll give you
seven dollars sure yeah there's that
that's to me that's a little shady
because you misinformed the person well
that's I think that's the message so
don't lie just just [ __ ] offer the
seven bucks and be away with it that's
the maximum worst when you're like let's
say your antique roadshow and you
purposely tell people that [ __ ] is worth
nothing and then you [ __ ] sell this
Pirate's Chef for [ __ ] millions of
dollars yeah that's different when
you're the authority on valuing it and
then you [ __ ] lie yeah like a open
door that's got a like penalties I
forget from who for like 62 million
dollars to do that because they would
tell people come sell to us you'll get
the max value and then people didn't get
the max value there it
but when a small guy does it then
they're not going to well also I think
when you say you'll get the max value
you know that's misleading yeah well
what is the max value right well but
that's concept yeah you're already like
putting yourself out there you got to
give people like that out right it's
like it's like knowing your skills
you're probably not going to get you
know more than seven dollars for this
Beanie Baby yeah you know what I mean
you gotta convince them you work the
corner yourself you might get beat up
and you only get x amount come with me
you're well protected you have health
care but hey but they're going to be
charged and how old is that profession
but at the end of the day the person
who's agreeing to it they're an adult
agreeing to selling the home selling the
beanie baby they didn't do their own
research and homework and the
information but they didn't care to it's
super simple right yeah they didn't
really like it wasn't a priority so how
many out of the 50 states which state do
you think got scammed the most
California it's not California no
Florida nope Oklahoma we got a thing
which was the dumbest state right
Mississippi
all right that's close Alabama no
Louisiana all right here I'll give you
options I know
South Dakota nope he said brass close to
Mississippi here it is between these
three between these three which one do
you think it is Oklahoma
Maine Massachusetts or New Hampshire
what I thought they're smart up there
which one do you think it is out of
those three I think Maine New Hampshire
they also have the smartest
[ __ ] MIT [ __ ] oh there you
go all the smart [ __ ] right
there the smartest and the dumbest
people just taking advantage because
they got more Ivy Leagues in there if
you ever stay right and they got it they
got aggressive people in Boston so yeah
that's true damn man yeah they show
that's a lot they're um like the losses
there for I think it says 2021 uh let's
say like when you look at uh the second
one which is New Hampshire 2.5 million
in losses Massachusetts 8.9 whoa uh in
scam losses pertaining to real estate
and Rental wow and then that's
drastically lower because most people
that get scammed don't report it because
they're [ __ ] embarrassed of course so
you can probably bet that's maybe like
5x in reality because there's a lot of
trustworthy people there and a lot of
shady people there there's good people
and then like most scams the perfect
victim are just like well-meaning old
people you know yeah or maybe like
incoming freshmen and students to all
those Ivy Leagues that aren't like
native to the area or or like there's a
lot on adults yeah yeah I mean or people
with bad credit that can't get a can get
a regular uh lease like oh you know what
this might have you know or like some
like Chinese person is coming over just
trying to study it like MIT doesn't
speak English that well it's like oh
Craigslist
out of all the websites too I know so
here's just to finish it off just to
like help people that are watching
here's the things to avoid so that you
don't become victims Craigslist do not
wire funds to people you don't know
don't put money towards a house you
haven't seen confirm the identity of the
landlord ask for an ID like even if it's
over correspondence be like hey send me
a picture of your ID don't fill out apps
online until you've met directly with
the manager know the local rental prices
look for online reviews and references
be wary if a tenant wants to rent
property unseen that's always a red flag
you guys could go to property management
companies too
yeah well I think most of the people who
are probably falling for this they don't
have the credit to go to a property
management right if it was me if
you tell me about yourself hear their
job occupation okay I can hustle this
person by hearing their occupation I can
talk and hustle them oh you get paid in
cash oh I'm charging them yeah but oh
you got a W-2 job never mind they're
gonna report me first of all another red
flag don't
um don't accept like if if the renter's
out of town and they want to cash your
check don't do it uh if they say they're
out of the country and want to uh the
rent sent to a foreign account don't do
it if the names don't match between the
person you're talking to and the account
you're sending to don't do it don't
accept overpayment for properties if you
receive a check for more than the
specified amount return it do not
deposit it and those are like the main
ways to avoid being scammed wait I don't
like that last one what if somebody
sends me more money don't deposit it I
was agreeing all the way until the last
one you've never been you've never
the car the car situation wait wait wait
explain it real quick they send you a
check and then it bounces but then you
need you they they need you to cut them
back the difference so let's say I'm
gonna send you 15 grand I need you to
send me back three grand because I
overpaid because I was at this Western
Union that's the only thing they had
that's the classic Nigerian scam
Minecraft because it's like oh I made a
big mistake can you wire my money back
yeah say [ __ ] you bye
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]